Thanks
everybody and thanks to the organizers I
know this is a
can it provide another value to the
community so I was I was reflecting on
this on this pre-packed room and
remembering home was 15 years ago when
my date that did not exist and we would
do the site by conferences and in
Caltech in Pasadena and we were just a
bunch of geeks and I remember I remember
preparing talks at the last minute
because it wasn't important and we were
just nobody well guess what stop
referring talks at the last minute
except now you guys have expectations so
the URL of my my talk is here you can
download the notebooks for instance by
browsing at the bottom these are
generated notebooks I must confess I
tend not to use to work a lot in the
notebook myself and there is also a
binder button on the web page so if you
click on it it tries to start a
cloud-based version of the notebooks
that you can play with the tutorial
without installing it it's been working
so and so proudly that the cloud is a
bit loaded and binder is not able to
give instances so if it doesn't work
don't raise your hand to tell me it
doesn't work but the challenge for me
here is to share some intuitions that I
have we have I guess in the end the team
and the various teams with which I work
with machinery models and share may be
things that we've learned and do this
based on code and data rather than a
whiteboard so I think the way I'll start
is going to be too slow for some of you
and if it's really too slow do complain
and then it'll go faster and faster and
depending on how fast we go
I might have too much material or we
might have some time for more playing
around with the data also I'd love if
you would interrupt me with questions I
mean ideally this is you know sharing
knowledge so I'm gonna move the URL out
so if people come in late could their
neighbors give them the URL
I've also tweeted it for those who
follow me and if you don't you should
just you know help with my ego problems
excellent so Ian doesn't know but I'm
slack adverse that's okay as long as I
don't have to so there are two points of
my tutorial the first part is measuring
and understanding how well our
classifier or actually I should say a
predictor in general predicts and the
second part is understanding a bit the
feature space and the length between the
features and the prediction and I'm a
very shallow person so I won't be doing
any deep learning so let's let's start
by looking at B at the metrics to judge
the success of a model and I'll switch
to just to to go along with you I'll
switch to the to the notebooks which you
might have downloaded and if you don't
have you can follow online it's not a
big deal and I'll open the metrics
notebook okay and what I'd like to talk
about here is the different metrics and
more importantly give some insights some
which ones are useful or rather than
useful which ones are important okay
whatever
insights on metric so let's first start
with loading some data so I'm going to
load the Boston housing data so this is
a data that relates the price of houses
in the Boston area with a bunch of
different feature is a
and I'm gonna split I'm gonna grab a
target and the data and then quickly
what I'll do is I'll plot the different
features and their links to what we're
trying to predict so here we have a
measurement of the crime rate in the
neighborhood and the price of the house
so we see that if the crime is really
low the price is high and if the crime
is high the price tends to be lower we
have I don't know what this is Zn we
have some measurement of the industrial
the amount of industrial activity in the
region chase is a binary variable 0 1
that it tells you whether you next to
the Charles River or not the Charles
River is a river in Boston so if you're
next to the charm River yeah
most likely it's more expensive I don't
know what Knox is REM is the number of
rooms houses with more rooms are more
expensive the age of the house younger
houses tend to be more expensive than
older houses the distance to
transportation and I don't know what
this is I'm not sure what this is I'm
not sure what this is this is a strange
function of the number of black people
in the district and it's a very strange
function on top of this and I don't
remember what this anyhow it's I'm very
biased I find it's useful to to know
what's your in your in your data I hate
this black box so let's now forget
what's in the data for a while and apply
a random force regressor to the data so
we're just going to instantiate the
model and then we're gonna try to
measure how well it predicts and the
standard way to do this in scikit-learn
is to use cross value give it the model
the data the target and it will do a
cross-validation internally in by
default it will return the explained
variance so the nice thing
so here it's done a three fold I could
tweak this but it's not a three fold
cross validation and it returns to
explain why
the nice thing about the explained
variance is its upper bounded by one so
the metrics and scikit-learn that are
returned by Croswell score are always
bigger is better okay
always so it's always bigger is better
but here it's upper bounded by one if I
have one I have perfect prediction and
if I have zero or actually slightly
below zero it's it's chance zero is the
prediction of the mean if you take the
mean of the trainsets and you apply it
to the test set that's zero in practice
chances worse than this people that
surprises people but chance is actually
worse than predicted in prediction of
the mean the reason is you get the mean
wrong okay so it's a nice metric because
it has a scaling that's somewhat
independent of the data so one is good
zero is bad and so now I can look at
whether my classifier works well if I am
along the if I'm not along the Charles
River
so the Charles River is feature three so
if I'm not along the Charles River I'm
selecting the the observations that are
there with Charles River equals zero and
I'm seeing something that's not very
different the reason I'm doing this is
there is a slight danger here so I could
I could I could compare along the
Charles River not along the Charles
River and I get significantly different
results but there's a slight danger here
is that we're looking at explained
volumes on different data sets so it's
plain variance you can think of it as
the fraction of the bars that I
explained but we're looking at two data
sets that actually have two different
variants so my point is when you're
trying to compare prediction on two data
sets explained variance is probably a
bad idea because you might simply be
able to predict on a data set with less
variance and have the same error
absolute error but achieve a better
explained variance okay does that make
sense
all right so in this end
we might want to use another metric and
the most classic one would be the mean
square so here we can just simply say
scoring equals negative mean square
error and the reason we're using the
negated mean square error is that bigger
is better
always and so then we can run this and
so we get the negated mean square error
away from the Charles River and close to
the Charles River in here we can really
compare those numbers they have the same
scaling and we can say well quite
clearly I'm not working as well if I'm
trying to predict things that are close
to the Charles River okay but here the
copper ism has a meaning now what's the
unit well it's it's just queer
difference and in dollars that's hard to
have a mean squared difference in
dollars it's hard to have an intuition
about this
so one metric that I like a lot is the
mean absolute error and the reason that
I like the mean absolute error a lot is
that it's unit is naturally related to
the scale of Y except here I'm not sure
what what the scale of why is it must be
some thousands of dollars maybe with a
log scale or something like this but but
anyhow in practice I use a lot in the
mean absolute error when I need to
report numbers that make sense in terms
of Y okay so I tend to use the explain
variance and the mean absolute error
that's for regression settings I was
trying to predict the price the price is
a continuous variable now for
classification settings I can lower the
digits data sets so for those who don't
know the digits a set is a set of small
images they're 8 by 8 so 64 features
there is 1500 images and each image
represents the digits back in white so
it's a multi-class problem with 10
classes and right now I'm going to try
to see whether I can
detect sevens or not using a random
force classifier
okay so I'm gonna create myself a target
that's 0 and 1 it's 1 when the digit is
a 7 and 0 when it's something else all
right and then I'm going to use
correspond score on this and when I use
cross balanced court on classification
problem by default it uses the
accuracies course so the average rate of
success okay so this one takes values
between 0 & 1 and 1 is perfect
prediction now let me instance it a very
stupid classifier in scikit-learn we
have this classifier that we call the
dummy classifier and let me instantiate
it with the strategy most frequent and
let's see how well it does it is pretty
well why does it work so well because I
have much more 0s than 1 ok so in terms
of minimizing the error the mean error
I haven't mean it's actually pretty good
to always take zeros by the way this is
a situation that happens often in real
life if you tell a cop that he needs to
always catch a certain type of
criminality he might actually end up
with this strategy so looking for
illegal migrants in a wizard arresting
people who are not white like himself so
the point here is that it's not a good
error of measure when the classes are
imbalanced when you have much more of
one class than on the other Clause then
the mean error is not a good measure of
error okay because you can go very high
by taking the most freaking Clause so
one thing that we can look at is the
precision so the precision is the ratio
of detections that are correct the
fraction of detection that
correct okay so I can use parseval's
core and use Corinne equals precision
and it gives me the precision oops got a
typo I know this is not a typo so the
precision for the real classifier is
quite high and now I can look at the
precision for the most freaking
classifier and it's giving me a warning
it's telling me that it's ill-defined
and the reason is ill-defined is that
the most frequent classifier here is
always predicting zeros okay and the
precision is how many corrects one did I
detect so I can't compute the precision
when I have over zero so what what
scikit-learn does then is it tells you
that the precision is is a zero which is
a good choice but if my classifier had
predicted a single one that would be
very different
okay now the flip side of the precision
is the recall it's the fraction of the
class one that I have actually detected
okay so precision how many class one are
correct deductions recall out of all the
class ones what's the fraction that I
have detected so these are two
complementary measures so I can use the
same thing and look at the recall of my
classifier and now my recall is slightly
less good so I'm I'm missing a lot of
sevens okay and I can I can look at the
recall of my most frequent what you
expect it to be
you just had coffee
so zero I expect it to be zero and it is
they were okay so precision and recall
are two complementary measures now
measuring only the precision without the
recall makes no sense because I can
increase arbitrarily my precision by
selecting less than less and less people
okay so the ad you the best way to do
this would be to compare classifiers
that a given recall so if I want to
detect this fraction of my population
what precision will I have now
unfortunately we don't have yet in
scikit-learn a way of tuning the
threshold so what I what I haven't said
is that you can you can arbitrary tune
the threshold of a bunch of classifiers
to push to recall or to push the
precision this might be useful in an
application if I'm trying to do
screening for breast cancer for instance
depending on what I will do with the
detection I might want a high recall I
won't want to detect everybody who's
likely to have a breast cancer or if I'm
going to do an invasive surgery I might
want a high precision okay so depending
on the application you would you'd
rather favor recall or precision and and
so so with many classifiers you can tune
the the fraction that you want by
threshold in a different way either the
decision function or the predict probe
at which our methods that many
classifiers provide now what would be
really good would be to scan the
threshold to fix a given recall and give
the precision there so there's an issue
to do this if anybody wants to do a poll
request try
is thinking about this while writing the
tutorial and I don't really see this dad
said no I guess I guess it's going to be
application dependent that said people
look much more precision at a given
recall and for me at least it's more
intuitive but that's totally going to be
dependent on the on the question and I I
could see that for medical applications
when you're doing a screening test you
might want an extremely high recall at
the cost of a low precision if your next
step is not invasive so we've seen a bit
this tension between precision and
recall and the fact that that it's a
trade-off basically and so one way of
looking at the full trade-off space is
to look at the ROC curve so who knows
who's has heard of the ROC curve that's
pretty good okay so it means I can speed
up okay
the ROC curve is basically the curve
that you get between true positive rate
and false positive rates so almost
precision and recall they're not exactly
the same thing but whatever when you
vary the threshold okay so the idea
being that you'd like your your your
true positive rate to jump as fast as
possible as you are increasing your
false positive rate okay so it basically
explores all the trade-offs and gives
you so so the metric that we used is the
area under the curve of the ROC and it's
pros all the trade-offs and gives you
the area on the under the curve so this
is a nice very nice metric in the sense
that chance is always point five even
with class imbalance so if you're trying
to compare different prediction problems
with different class imbalances and it's
it's actually very useful now we can
also look at the average precision so
the average precision is somewhat
similar to the AUC under the ROC curve
it's the average precision for all the
recalls it's not exactly the
it's related one is the monotonic
function of the other but the dynamical
range of the average precision is much
more linear when you have severely
imbalanced class so what I'm telling you
is that so one is the monotonic function
an increasing function of the other
right so you can always link the two but
if you have extremely balanced classes
you're gonna have tiny differences in
our C curve that make big differences in
average precision so one one you have
very large imbalances I can't you like
to prefer average precision okay
and the drawback is that chance is no
longer at 0.5 all right now so far I've
looked at the specific problems trying
to predict only sevens but my original
problem had ten classes so if we go back
to the original problem and then we try
to look at the error on the ten classes
well the the standard measure of error
that we use so the the accuracy score
extends naturally to the ten classes how
many successful predictions that I make
was the average rate of successful
prediction that's that's easy we also
need to keep in mind that the most
freaking label is no longer a very
interesting baseline so here we use a
uniformly random baseline and it does
approximately 1 over 10 which is which
is what we would expect so the the
problem there is that something like
precision and recall are no longer
defined without the choice of a positive
class okay I need to single out a class
to define precision and recall I can
define precision and recall per class
but the average one overall class is not
well-defined and so one thing that we
can do is transform the problem in a
prayer and what's known as a multi label
problem it's a multi label problem is
that you're trying to affect one or more
labels at each instance and one way of
thinking about this is if you use
old-style mailers you're putting your
mail in folders if you use Gmail you're
adding labels to your mail okay so
multi-class is exclusive with the class
multi labels is non-exclusive so if we
transform the problem in a multi label
then the precision and the recall and in
the ROC curve and the average precision
are well-defined okay so we can do this
by using the level minor Iser
that and applying it to the to the
labels for problem and that transforms
our problem in a multi label right so
it's multiple zero one prediction
problems this is this is the new the new
set of labels and now I can apply my our
C curve and it gives me an hour C which
is the ROC for each label okay and I can
do also the same thing for the average
precision now importantly the link
between this and the accuracy is
basically multi closet multi-level are
not the same thing Multi late multi
classes exclusive multi-level is not so
it's this is you can't just say this is
a trivial extension of roc for a multi
multi class it's not because and when
you're varying threshold you might have
confusion between labels okay so it's
just just to keep in mind that roc an
average precision or unfortunately not
as well defined in multi class problems
which is a pity because I find them very
useful so as a summary in single cloth
settings I tend to always use either ROC
a you see on the near receive for a
reasonably well balanced problem and for
extremely advanced problem average
precision and multi class problems then
I need to think a bit more and I might
also look at ROC for each class that's
something I do okay any questions on
this now I'm going to slow this is
trivial very good good news
okey-dokey now I will switch to the I
believe I'm switching to the
cross-validation I could have given them
numbers so I'm switching yes I am
switching to cross-validation and I'd
like to talk a little bit more about
cross-validation because it's oh no it's
not as trivial I mean there are few
gotchas basically okay the first thing
I'd like to look at is the in certainty
of cross-validation okay so here I'm
just gonna do a data set and I think it
has 200 samples and it's just blobs that
are centered on 0 0 and 0 1 in a 2d
space so it's a bit of a trivial data
set and I'm applying it alone it's a
linear discriminant analysis because
it's simple I don't want to worry about
these things and then I'm going to look
at the cross-validation scores so this
is the accuracy score on the data and I
mean you can notice that it has a bit of
a spread so what what happens if I
shuffle the data and rerun this so here
I'm shuffling the data 10 times then I'm
rerunning and I'd like to stress the
spread of these results if you look at
them I mean results go from 0.58 2.8 is
there a point 8 yes there's a point 8 so
it's a very large spread why is that
okay let's let's step back a minute
and let's just think probability suppose
my classifier is trained and it will
predict the correct response with a
probability of 0.7 the 70% of the time
we predict was pretty surprised the
correct response
now I'm observing I'm testing it at
times where aim is my number of samples
okay so then the the there the observed
the observed accuracy follows a binomial
law it's basically flipping a coin with
a point seven a chance of being on one
side or the other so that's probability
tells us it's a binomial law so I'm
following a binomial law with number of
degrees of freedom which is given by the
the size of my data set and the
probability of the binomial that is that
is 0.7 if my my real classifiers
accuracy is 0.7 okay so this I can I can
take slide by stats and instance eight
this distribution it's it's well known
the formulas are well known and then I
can predict it it's probability mass
function okay so here I've just
renormalized that in in in accuracy okay
so what you're seeing is that it is
indeed centered at 0.7 but it has a
certain width and that width is just
sampling noise you know if I flip my
coin a hundred time and I average I'm
still going to get some uncertainty and
that isn't tiny that's the point and
there's nothing you can do you will not
get better than this if you're closer to
a hundred percent accuracy it will
narrow a bit right because it can't go
above a hundred percent but this is this
is the best you can do alright so now
you're gonna tell me well you've
generated only two hundred samples so
it's a tiny data set so of course you're
gonna run in trouble but by the way many
people unfortunately
machine learning models on 200 samples
because they do biomedical imaging like
me and they don't have many subjects and
and we run in problems so here what I'm
doing is I'm just doing a bit of a bit
of probability to look at the interval
in which 95% of my results land okay
that's the width of the interval in
which 95% of my results land and I'm
doing this as a fraction as a function
of the sample size so with a hundred
sample my width we're 95% of my reisel
land is around 20% so I've got plus and
minus 10% error on my prediction
accuracy if I have a hundred percent so
take-home message don't do it if I have
a thousand then I'm looking at 6% if I
had 10,000 I'm looking at 2% 10,000 2%
10,000 is I mean we would almost like
it's big I I would disclaimer I would
have expected that if I gain one percent
improvement if I'm working on 10,000
samples this is significant I'm safe I
can believe my cross validation know
maybe I'm Nev but I expected this before
I did these things actually I'm doing a
slight simplification here I'm
forgetting about this size and and train
size and looking at the complete dataset
because then I have in mind that we're
doing cross validation not validation
set and so on this is the best you're
ever gonna get by the way if you do more
sophisticated experiments on real dates
and you look at stability you're gonna
get worse things I have a paper out by
the way complaining about this because
in my community we we have a hundred
subjects so but but this is the best
you're ever gonna get this is assuming
your there's no dependency between the
folds of your of your cross-validation
there is
well the mean the mean is close this
I'm giving basically what I'm giving you
is is if those five numbers were
independent I'm giving you the the the
distribution of the mean okay
they're not by the way and I'm gonna
come back to this but if they were I'm
giving you the distribution in the mean
so that's the best ever you're gonna get
this that's a good comment so they're
good and bad ways of doing cross
validation and maybe I'll cover it if I
have time and so so yes so the point if
you have a hundred thousand which is
definitely considered as big data then
point five is is the wit and it defeats
me people are forgetting this people in
deep learning have been training Ganz on
things and then seeing point five
percent increase in a metric that is
quite meaningless and publishing
publishing publishing publishing and
then five years down the line these
people wake up and they go like ooh
we've been mining noise because because
they have waked up woken up they wake up
and they say well we've been mining
noise this is basic probability and you
know going back to cross-validation also
something that worries me is that people
do train test split or actually train
test validation they phrase their
validation their validation sets then
then the the width of the binomial is
given by the validation set right so
when you don't have humongous amount of
data you should do cross validation this
is all bad news because it means you're
going to be burning CPU or GPU telling
by the way does that use for me too
okay so which which cross-validation
which is something I I I haven't let me
let me let me answer it is but first let
me just conclude them the fact that it's
important to have in mind that cross
validation is no other ground truth that
is an estimation like all estimation it
has errors and there's nothing you can
do about it so what okay how do I do
cross validation and there is the food
culture and machine learning with a
bunch of proofs and experiments like so
little food cultures tells you that you
should leave between 10 and 20 percent
of your data out so so if we're looking
at your standard key fault we're looking
at 5 to 10 a careful but one thing that
I tend to do is I do things like
repeated key fold or what we call
shuffle split or stratified triple
splits to basically increase a bit the
sampling that's sad to come back to your
point and not seeing more data you know
I will not get past those bounds I'm
getting closer to those bounds so
basically cross-validation is worse than
those bounds I'm getting closer to those
bounds but I'm not getting past those
bends exactly so in general the more
folds I use and the more repetitions I
do the closer I get to this I tend to do
a 100 shuffle split these days which is
which is a bit expensive so something I
wanted to talk about but I couldn't find
a public data set on which it was it was
a was obvious is confounding effects and
on independence so another dependence
there's a simple example as you're
looking at time series if you really
want to maximize your cross-validation
just like one point out of two and your
time serie and you're going to predict
really well because you're going to
predict the point from the two neighbors
okay that's quite obvious the core
problem here is for a cross-validation
to work I need independence between the
train and the test set okay so people
who do time series tend to have this
tend to be quite aware of this now
suppose another problem and suppose I'm
trying to do a biomarker of a disease so
basically look at
biomedical imaging signal and try to
detect this this disease suppose I have
sampled the patient's several time so I
have a data set with many patients and
I've sampled some of them several times
it's really important that those
patients are either all in the test set
or all in the train set right because
elsewhere my conclusion is it's still a
valid conclusion but not for my usage it
doesn't mean that I'm predicting to new
patients if it means I'm predicting to
new data but not of different patients
so here I have I have a confounding
structure and non dependence structure
and in scikit-learn you can use the the
the their group splitters there is a
bunch of stratified group and well no
group shuffle splits and I believe group
K folder I don't remember the names but
they're called group something okay and
so what what we do the way we use them
is that we create a vector of a group
indicator suppose and then the splitter
will separate out the each label of each
group in a different folder and it won't
put basically two instances with the
same label in the in train no it won't
put the same label in the test and in
the train set okay is that clear
alright and I won't go into more details
here this is in what I do so biomedical
imaging this is crucial but I a magical
imaging data tends not to be public
makes my like life hard because when I
do such a tutorial I need to find new
data okay one last thing
measuring baseline and chance to avoid
wasting time it's important to have a
good idea what is a simple baseline or
1s chance and we've already seen the
Demi classifier so the Demi classifier
has a bunch of different strategies and
the most simple one is the the
stratified one in which it tries to
predict with the same distribution as as
why image in the train set okay it's
basically learning the distribution of Y
but not learning the distribution of Y
and X jointly or conditionally okay and
then you can do most frequent you can do
uniform you bunch of things you can do
the other thing that you can do is if
you want to know the value of chance is
actually easy to get it wrong about the
value of chance because there might be
all kind of class imbalances and things
like this then you can use the
permutation score so what the
permutation score will do is it will
permute VY's across the the samples
across the observations so basically
break the link between y and X and then
learn and do cross validation on this
and then it will do also cross
validation the none per mutant and it
will return three things it will return
the score on the non per mutant the
permutation scores and then a p-value
which is basically the probability of
the observed score in the per muted
score in the permitted scores okay yes
kidding regression well that's what that
would be a dummy dummy regression other
than we classify I think it's the same
default because most frickin might be
something extremely unstable if you have
a very balanced clause so I don't think
we would put most frequent as a default
but if you even in dance class it's
probably question is you want the truth
or the posterior many of it I mean some
some people would think I'm not
interested in a point estimate I'm
interested in posterior and that I mean
if it might be important there so
basically if you doing a statistical
analysis of the scores you interested in
a posterior not in a point estimate if
you're just going to make a decision
maybe that based on the score that's all
you're interested in okey-dokey any
other questions here
well there's two things there is either
what's I could burn those or what we
tend to do in the lab it's like an urn
will refit we have found on the kind of
horrible that you're the kind of harmful
data that you and I work on that because
we work on small data sets we have found
that it can be useful to do what's known
sometimes as CV bagging so Chris
validation bagging is to do cross
validation on each fold pick the model
that performs best and then average
those model do model averaging on these
it's it's it's the kind of stuff that's
published in a bunch of different places
you know people put this in the
footnotes and we put it in the footnote
in our papers and it would gain having a
bit more popularity because the rule of
psychic learning is we can put inside
you learn new things that are popular
okay so I'd love to I'd love to have
this in secular and I think it works
extremely well so CV bagging okay you do
cross validation you select on each fold
you select the best hyper parameter and
then you just do a bagging model on this
it tends to be much more robust the
reason is that because of the variance
of cross validation that I mentioned
earlier selecting high parameters is
actually noisy it's an overfit so when
you're averaging instead of refitting
when you're averaging those multiple
models with different IP parameters you
tend to get in in an in-sample model
that's quite robust okay any other
questions
all right so now what should I talk
about Oh underfitting versus overfitting
so it's where underfitting versus
overfitting hmm not sure why the
notebook is not there probably because
the script is crashing sorry
Oh oh yes of course them because the
notebooks are first thank you okay so
now what I'd like to cover is this is
actually quite classic by the way is
where they're basically had to
understand whether your model can can be
improved and how to improve it okay and
and I quickly want to give intuitions on
the most important thing of machine
learning which is which is
regularization and overfitting so just a
toy model so this is just a generating
function that if you look at it it's
basically 10 minus 1 over X and a bit of
noise and we're going to try to use
polynomial regression on this so we're
going to fit this using a basis of
polynomials and the reason we do this is
it's simple to understand right it's
just a linear regression where the basis
of polynomials and here we have an
important hyper parameter which is the
degree of the polynomial do I want to
use you know a polynomial of degree 10
or do I want to use a polynomial of
degree 1 in which case I'm just doing a
linear regression okay so the way I'm
gonna create in scikit-learn polynomial
regression is I'm going to do a pipeline
between something that creates
phenomenal features okay by transforming
all my features into into their
different degrees and the linear
regression right so that's my model it's
it's
and there's pipeline and then I'm just
going to to generate a bit of data and
here I'm just generating data with only
eight samples because it's easier to
have any an intuition okay
and let me fit a polynomial of degree
one to this so polynomial of degree one
is a straight line so by the way the big
crosses are the data points for which I
have seen data and the faint data and in
in the background is data that I haven't
seen it's more detail generated from the
model so the model doesn't have access
to this so we can we can see the fit
here it's not a great fit and surprising
and we can see this by looking at the
Train error so this is a swing variance
and the Train error is not great we're
expending 50% of the variance and we can
look at the tests Erin so the error that
on the data the model hasn't seen and
the test error is on the same order of
magnitude okay now I can fit a
polynomial of degree six and this is
what it looks like
the good news is the trains course
fantastic I'm going to Oscar raise from
my boss the bad news is if I blame you
take time this is worked very well all
right what has happened we've over
fitted it was noise in the train detail
we've learned that noise okay and that's
the difference between the train in the
test data and I could play with this and
I could you know look at the different
degrees and find the one that fits the
data Bastyr and the one that fits the
data best which is something like - okay
for two we have 0.8 in train and point
six in test and for three let's look at
degree three we have twelve point eight
again and point seven so three is
probably better okay so now what I can
do is do this in a systematic way I can
generate so now I'm going to use a
larger test set a larger train set
because this was a bit ridiculous and
then what I can do so I'm going to split
it in training tests and so that's my
data okay I've got training test and
then what I'll do is I'll use validation
curve from from scikit-learn
to vary the degree of polynomial and
what validation curve will do is each
time compute the train test and that the
the train error and the test error and
do this in a cross validation loop okay
to decrease it at the variance of the
trainer in the tester all right so I can
do this and I can plot how the trainer
in the test area vary as I increase the
the degree of the polynomial okay
so what we can see is that the the score
of training tends to be better than
there's the scores testing and we can
see that it's almost equal to the score
of
for a while and it grows quickly as
model complexity increases and test so
Christ's validation score also grows and
at some point training score continues
to grow but cross-validation score
decreases okay so that's the that is
this is the classic a curve as we're
increasing model complexity we're going
from a regime where we're under fitting
so we have a very large train error and
a similar test error to a regime where
we're overfitting where the Train error
is much smaller than the tester okay so
it's important to have those two regimes
in mind if you are in under fitting
regime you need more data know if you're
under fitting regime you need more
complex models okay if you're
overfitting regime you need more data or
less complex models if you can't get
more data always good to have in this in
life okay the other interesting thing to
do is we can vary the amount of data and
we can look at different model
complexity varying the amount of data
okay so what we can see is that for a
degree one basically we really don't
need more than than 50/50 samples okay
for degree five things plateau out quite
quickly and for degree 15 well with
where the hundred and eighty sample
we're still wishing to get more sample
so there's no point increasing model
complexity here all right well that's
also interesting if you're in a
application setting if you know whether
it's really useful to acquire more data
or not okay
so just me the take-home message here is
it's useful to compare training test
error because it's going to tell us
whether we're more in overfitting
regimes or more in underfitting regimes
okay any questions on this yes
that's and that's an important question
so basically if you're doing cross
validation for hyper parameter selection
okay so you're gonna choose the best
high performing just basically what are
we doing here and that's a very
important question what we're doing here
to select so here to select so if we
take the maximum of the cross-validation
score and we use this as our hyper
parameter we need to test this on new
data we need to test this on the reason
being that that there's variance here
and we are gonna get it wrong
okay so then what you do is what you is
most known as nested Christ nomination
so basically you don't do it the way
I've done it you use an object that will
select the best type of parameter by
itself
so typically grid search CV or random
search CV and socket learn so there are
objects that do it for you and then this
object that you cross validated what I'm
saying is using your cross validation on
top of a cross validation so now if
you're doing 100 triple splits for this
you have 10,000 loops so then maybe you
need to think try to avoid problems okay
and in in this sense it might be more
important to do many cross validation
loops in the outer loop so the model
evaluation loop rather than the inner
loop the model selection loop okay any
other questions
okay so now now we're going to go to
understanding in the feature space we'll
try to understand the features that
basically how the classifier predicts
and I will start with something that is
not scikit-learn
that is completely I can take no credit
for it
I'm almost copy pasted their example so
who knows why I'm here
good that's like 10% so what lime does
is so the goal here is to answer the
question why how does the classifier
predict what are the features that are
relevant tell me a story about about how
this works and this is extremely
important a really light stress that
this is important because in many cases
you want you you you want to have
intuitions about how it works because
the data might change because you're
working with people who understand the
data because you're going to put this
because you're going to couple this with
human decisions okay so people will will
ask this a lot so if you want to follow
along by the way you need to install
lines so pip install lime and I
personally always install things this -
- user because this installs it in your
local directory if you're running on a
multi user environment okay so what line
does is that it does local approximation
local linear approximations of the
decision okay so the idea being that if
you have a nonlinear classifier so if
you have a linear model the decision
rule is the same everywhere but if you
have nonlinear model depending on where
you are the decision rule might bear it
so the kind of questions that you might
want to answer is you're asking to get a
loan and you've just been told you're
not getting the loan so you're asking
the bank how can I improve to get the
loan what can I do to get the loan
that's the kind of question and so the
kind of things that we would like to
report is well based on what we have
measured if you're age by the way was
larger than you would get the loan
so basically wait okay and so the way
the way life does it is for each sample
it will explore the local decisions and
create a linear approximation and then
report this in your approximation in the
original feature space okay does that
make sense I find this very clever by
the way I I have nothing to do with
inventing this so what we're doing here
is we're loading the the Boston data
we're splitting between training tests
we're taking a random for aggressor and
we're fitting it then lime likes to know
which features are categorical so I'm
going to just separate out which
features are categorical from the Boston
data and I use a heuristic that is
anything that has less than 10 unique
values I will call categorical and then
I will import from Lima
an explainer what lime calls an
explainer and they have different
explainers depending on the the type of
data you had and so here I'm looking in
the Boston data and it's typically a
tabular data so in state their work
columns have names okay and they have
they have explainers for image data and
text data okay so I'm instance saying
the explainer are telling it the feature
name so that it can report things in a
nice way telling it the name of what I'm
trying to predict which features are
categorical and that I want to do a
regression in so I'm giving it the train
data and then I'm going to ask it to
explain a given instance and I will give
it the the prediction function okay and
I'll tell it to report them 10 10
features and the important thing is I'm
telling it to explain a given instance
okay because the explanation is going to
be different for each instance which
wouldn't be the case if we had a linear
model because the gradient of a linear
model is uniform
okay and then I can I can plot it using
a spy plot figure all right so what
we're getting here is as I said so the
gradient in the in the original feature
space so it's basically telling me if I
varied this feature would I quickly get
closer to one yesterday well closer here
this is a regression problem so what I
quickly increase yes or no okay line has
explainers for image or basically it's
it's reporting this this gradient in the
image space or for text where it's
reporting the gradient by put seeing
colors on words okay I can also retrieve
the the explanation is a list of each
feature and what is dense board okay and
here here because we're using a random
forest you can see that it's actually
giving me brackets of the values of
features okay so if you were using a
different model it would be different so
I can I can do this for a bunch of
different instances and I'll find a
bunch of different explanations that
vary so that the challenge that we have
here with understanding those
predictions is that
we're trying to understand a function in
a high dimensional space here we have a
dozen features and we have one class
which is the price so we have a high
dimensional space and we're trying to
look at what varies when a very one and
and and not the other or the other okay
so we could do an exercise and do this
for a linear model for instance or even
better for a polynomial regression do we
want to do this I think we have time
this will wake you up
don't copy don't watch what I'm doing so
I'm gonna do this for polynomial
regression that you should be doing it
okay so it was basically a matter of
copy pasting and not getting it wrong
copy pasting and then what I'm
interested in is comparing those two and
to me yeah so this icon compared cuz
it's not the same instance I should put
the instances in the so here I am indeed
looking that's my at my at my linear
model well my it's not a linear model by
the way it's a polynomial model which is
and Here I am looking at my that my
random forests regressor and then I need
to match the instances the first
instances instance 25 so now I'm
matching the instances so this is
interesting that the problem is they're
not ordered the same way so it's quite
difficult to compare actually but we can
see that so here we have the age and
here we have the age so we can also see
that the thresholds are somewhat
arbitrary determined by lime they're not
properties of our model because we're
using two to two very different models
and then the model of polynomial
regression has no no notion of threshold
unlike the the the random forests and so
we can also see that for the same
instance the the rules are quite
different that's going back to this idea
that there's noise in the data things
aren't perfect we can't fully trust we
should like fully we should over
interpret those results and if I were to
use this a bit seriously which which I
haven't by the way disclaimer
used lime seriously so far which I were
if I were to use this a bit seriously I
think I would I would like bootstrap or
run a cross-validation fold and and try
to aggregate a bit results across across
a lime okay there are all kind of
reasons why this won't be stable the
first one is the the model itself is
unstable when we fitted the second one
is I'm I wouldn't be surprised that lime
itself is unstable okay
any questions on that good okey dokey so
now I promised that I would talk about
interpreting linear models so let's
let's try to talk about this
and by the way part of this is and while
most of this is unrelated to machine
learning and it's pretty much standard
statistics and part of this is related
to tutorial I gave a few years ago in a
Cambridge for the your sci-fi conference
and which is now part of the statistics
chapter of the slide by lecture notes
and so if you don't know statistics and
linear models like I suggest you have a
bit of look at it because it's the basic
of statistics so here let's look at a
data set of wages it's a public data set
that so here the code that we have here
downloads it and it gives a bunch of
different features things like education
so it's in the US the gender of the
person how many years of experience
whether the person is in union or not
the wage which is what we're going to
try to predict the age of that person
whether the person is married or not
lots of things okay so here we're just
managing the data to reconstruct a data
frame and we're taking the log of the
wage because wage is typically vary in a
multiplicative way so it's it's easier
to look at the log and now before
prediction I just like to look at the
data and to do a pair plot of the data
and that would be a bit of a big pair
plot so I've selected a subset of the
variables I've selected wage age
education and experience okay so I mean
here we can see how wage relates to okay
let's do it this way here we can see how
wage relates to experience education and
age so basically which increases with
education but not for everybody
increases with age and increases with
experience but not for everybody each
time okay anything striking about this
instance
and surprising but still striking okay I
can do it here if it's easier for you to
see yeah
age and experience are sitting severely
correlated unsurprising this is why it
is hard to find somebody with 15 years
of experience in spark as some
recruiters are asking not because all of
the spark coders are younger than than
15 by the way okay so it's just like to
stress this this this problem and now so
if we're trying to find so here we're
trying to find a link between age and
well we're trying to find the link
between noise variables and wage so we
can see that wage well it's kind of hard
to see here but wage increases with age
where can we see it here somewhat which
increases with age wage increases with
education wages increases with
experience all these are true statements
what I like to stress that is these are
what's known as marginal links between
age and the variable so it's the link
between the the target and the variable
but not taking in account the other ones
okay so the fact that a that wage
increases with age
is it mediated by the experience yes or
no I'd like to stress this because it's
just crazy how the lack of understanding
of these things is polluting things like
public discourse or even scientific work
people forget about the fact that
variables are related and that one link
may be mediated by another and people
don't understand what I'll talk about
next which is conditioning which is what
if I remove the effect of experience on
the age does that is there anything left
okay so
you near our each feature selection do
you know about univariate feature
selection so in scikit-learn its spare
not feature selection dots one of the
various things will select variables
based on their marginal link not based
on their condition okay it's important
to have this in mind the other thing
that's important to have in mind is that
what's a linear model does is it
computes conditional links well what
most multivariate models do is they
compute conditional links and linear
model just computes basically
conditional correlations so partial
correlations that's that's basically
what it does so basically you can think
of it as removing the effect of a larger
other features on each feature why am i
stressing this because it's important to
interpret the coefficients of a linear
model okay so marginal versus
conditional is a crucial aspect of
interpretation whether it's locally or
globally so now we can we can use a
linear model in this and we can use the
rich CV so while rich CV because it's
the simplest one that runs faster makes
little assumptions okay and then we can
visualize the coefficients okay and then
those coefficients are conditional
relationships between the wage and the
variable conditioning on the other ones
okay so it's basically for instance age
here is negative negatively related to
wage why because I've removed the effect
of experience so after removing the
effect of experience so with a given
experience if you're older you get less
well paid then what kind of horrible
things right in this in this dataset
so once again in terms of interpretation
maybe for me that's the most important
thing you know marginal conditional
important to have in mind is that it's
hard to estimate conditional
probabilities so once again I would
probably have to rerun this several
times and instead of plotting a single
bar plot to plot box plots to accumulate
data and there are many reasons why it's
hard to condition and the other thing to
keep in mind is that this is knowledge
statistical test
I have variance in the data I need to
correct for a bunch of different things
to correct for the variance of the data
and if the features are not too
correlated and there is plenty of
features then this is just kind of
statistics or nothing machine learning
and it's useful to know it and stat
models is very good for these for these
things right the stats model library is
very good okay but we happen to have
high dimensional data and it's
correlated and everything and we need to
use regularization okay and so for
instance one thing that we could do is
we could use a low su well what a low su
is is it's a linear model that seeks
some sparsity so it tries to select a
small number of variables to explain
well the the data and the su cv just
Tunes its hyper parameter to do this so
what what do we see when we rerun this
we've seen that a few number a few
variables have disappeared specifically
occupation and experience so the number
of variables that disappear has been
attuned by cross-validation it's quite
interesting to see the experiences
disappeared with intuition we would
expect experience to be one of the most
important factors of wage why has it
disappeared because it can be explained
by age okay so the problem we have here
is that we have highly correlated
variables it's very hard to select which
one is relevant the su models so the su
is based on l1 penalty like most sparse
models
farce models when they have a lot of
highly correlated features they will
select one out of the several and this
selection is very unstable and typically
they select the one with the larger
sister not the largest
thus most noise I didn't say this he
said this it is a slip of language but
yeah no but that set here it's that you
the proper use one has experienced being
removed out of the model because it can
be explained by age but the thing is
that it's probably I don't know is I
didn't do a real study on this but it's
probably just an assent our problem and
experiences is hi you made it it's
harder to measure than age and that's
why it left but what we would need to do
really is to bootstrap this model and to
look at what selected then this if you
really are interested in these things
this is the way you need to do it but
even there's a literature on this and
it's hairy and it doesn't work well
that's okay any other questions on this
okay so take a messages both marginal
and conditional links are interesting in
terms of interpretation you need to
understand the difference you need to
have in mind that conditional links are
hard to estimate that in on top of this
we almost always use models that have
some form of regularization it's not
always as brutal as a sparsity but its
presence this regularization makes
arbitrary choice it's almost the
definition of regularization you need to
have this in mind and it tends to be
unstable you need to perturb your model
and see how robust it is okay
okay now I want to talk about random
forests which I don't know as well as
linear models okay so we're just gonna
unload this same exact data set and the
only the only important point that I
need to make about random forests is
that they come with a measure of feature
importance
so in scikit-learn it's it's the future
importance attribute and it's it's some
form of estimates between the mutual
information there's some form of
estimate of the mutual information
between the feature and the target but
there are lots of precautions to take
here first thing is there is not only
one definition of future importance so
for instance in in the are packages that
the random forest is a forest of
different feature importance and they
all have their own problems
and the second thing is this an estimate
of the mutual information between the
feature in the target conditionally on
the other features but only partially
conditionally okay and let me explain a
bit more if okay so with with the random
forest I can tune the depth of the tree
if I do a depth of one my random forest
is only computing the feature
importances marginally if I do a long
depth my random forest is conditioning
on the variables that are associated in
the same tree and that conditioning is
not probably on all the variables
because I probably haven't covered all
the marbles that depending on me okay
and the other thing to have in mind
that if I have a categorical variable
and some using a criteria like the Gini
criteria for random forests there is a
bias in the estimation of feature
importance is that they're higher the
cardinality of the categorical variable
the higher the future importance will be
okay so there are all kinds of biases in
future importances and people who want
to understand these things really well
they do things like they're kind they're
permute one feature and look at its
future importance under the null and
this is its own limitation because when
you're permitting one feature you might
be breaking a correlation structure so
for instance if i permuting the age and
and not the experience i'm gonna have
people that are more experienced than
their old okay any questions on this
good I got away with it
and one last thing
partial defenses then see blocks so the
ID the concept be it be behind partial
dependency flaws is that you can think
of your model it's a bit similar to line
in the sense that you can think of your
model now just think of your model is
your ground truth as the data the data
that you didn't have that you would have
liked to hand and then you can run some
some form of post hoc statistical
analysis on this so basically use your
model to predict and look at the lengths
of the variables that are predicted okay
so we're gonna work on the Boston the
Boston dataset and unfortunately in the
psychic learn currently the partial
dependency plots only work with written
and boosted regression trees because of
the way they're implemented this is very
unfortunate but there's a bit of work to
be done there and so what what the the
partial dependency plot is it's going to
do is it's going to evaluate the model
predictions by varying one of the feet
and looking at how the prediction varies
when we vary this feature and it will
marginalize
the other feature it will average out
the other features so once again the
picture I have in mind is I have a high
dimensional space which is the space of
all my features I have a prediction in
this high dimensional space I'm going to
varying one feature and average all the
others ok so we have a simple only one
plotting functions to do this it's
called block partial dependence and you
give it the list of features or Affairs
of features
so maybe the example will make things
more clear here I'm looking at the
influence of crime on the on the on the
price and you can see that basically
there is some form of a jump where when
this crime measurement goes from for 2
to 6
ok Charles River and things are slightly
more expensive when you're close to the
Charles River than far away from the
Charles River the number of room houses
are more expensive than when I have
rooms more rooms and this is here I'm
looking at interactions between between
features so the interaction between five
and zeros so between crime and rooms and
it seems that when the house has a lot
of rooms then the crime rate is not
important but when the house has a small
number of rooms then the crime rate is
important same thing I would do some
form of perturbation analysis on this to
trust it by the way and there is a
corresponding lower level function that
you give it the target feature and you
give it the resolution of the grid
because this guy is going to computer
grid in feature space
right so this may be a bit expensive and
then it returns all the partial
dependencies and you need to reshape
them to be able to have them on the
grader and so you can run this and then
we can finish with a 3d plotting and
here we're seeing the same thing that we
were seeing here the interaction between
crime and the number of room but in 3d
except we've done things a bit more
manually this might be interesting if
you want to do you know some form of
perturbation analysis I'm from a postdoc
statistical analysis okay in theory
there's no reason why this couldn't be
applied to different models it's just
that the computation cost on different
models here there are ways the ways it's
implemented avoids too much computation
if you were to evaluate the models on
large grids it would be a killer okay
seems we're finishing early that's all I
have so you guys didn't have any
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you're asking one you mean test what
so the question is I want to compare two
models using cross-validation how do I
test this when you mean test what is the
sense you're putting behind test so the
word test is an important one so if
you're doing test in the sense of so if
you've done only one split it's that
somewhat easy because well somewhat easy
yet two measures but Jenny you have two
measures by the way that's the problem
so you don't have a measure of their
variance the challenge is you don't have
a vision measure the variance of the
mean prediction you can either have a
bunch of predictions in which case you
have but you have to sentence two
samples or you only have one measure and
if you're doing cross validation you're
not getting more measures because
they're not independent and it's
provable that there's in general you
come you can't decouple their their
independence so if you're doing if you
want to do a test in the freakin test
statistic meaning you cannot I mean I
know if no paper in this but we've
convinced we've looked at the problem a
bit in my group well more than a bit and
we've convinced ourselves that you
cannot there are a bunch of papers that
show you how you can do
yes if you have a bunch of different
data sets because then each of the set
is bringing you a data pointer and so
the way around this I believe is you
flip the problem and you're like okay
today I'm gonna be Bayesian and you
think of this as a posterior and then
what I do you can the best way to do
this and it's not in scikit-learn
unfortunately it would be to do
bootstrap 6 to 3 so what the bootstrap 6
to 3 is is you're randomly subset your
your your your data points
no well you you run bootstrap so you
randomly choose data points and on
expectation you're gonna have 1 - 6 - 3
fraction of the data that are not chosen
by your boot strap these you keep out
and you define them as test so training
your model on a bootstrap replicate of
your data you're the out of out of bag
you use this test you do this many many
many times this you consider as a
bootstrap distribution of your test
measure okay so now you have a bootstrap
it's a tutor posterior and so now you
can do this with two models and compare
the pseudo posteriors this will work
sorry
I know just do a t-test and compare yet
know doesn't work
those didn't work doesn't work I've
convinced myself that doesn't work
because you need to control for the
degrees of freedom in there okay let me
give you a good example I do a
stratified shuffled splits and I do ten
iterations and the difference between my
two models is not significant that's
okay I'm gonna crank this up and do 100
iterations okay when I do this I'm
artificially increasing than the degrees
of freedom of my test even though I've
not seen any more data so I could just
crank this up and crank this up and
crank this up and crank this up so this
is really telling me that are not seeing
independent observations I'm really
sampling a posterior so you and when
you're selling a posterior you can't do
free to the free
yeah frequencies test you can also you
can only do like Bayesian model
comparison or whatever you want come on
yeah but-but-but the grep that I showed
were computable in binomial distribution
that's why they were like the empirical
grass actually differ they're wider this
the the real graphs now this is the
route graphs are application specific
why because you don't thought for this
you've got variance if your classifier I
didn't put it taking account the
variance of the classifier on top of
this you're gonna have correlation
between your samples so your number of
degrees of freedom is wrong on top of
this you have your your cross-validation
40g that changes so really I mean if you
want I can pull up one of my recent
papers really what we do is we do
something that looks like the bootstrap
a 6:32 is 6 if it's not in circular but
like many many randomized shuffled
splits and then we look at the
distribution of what it gives us and we
consider this as a posterior it's very
costly unfortunately but at least we
have the impression that we were doing
something that's somewhat control and on
published papers when I did where I did
you know wilcoxon signed-rank test wrong
I know it I know last year I realized
this and I got worried I did write to
paper yeah I need to write they're black
boys yes I do I've done a lot of working
and civilized machine learning and my
conclusion on this is the way you
benchmarking and supervised machine
learning problem is you use it as some
foreign with feature generation or
something like this for supervised
problem because elsewhere you're just
benchmarking your bias so either you
have labels in which case you should be
using this because if you have label
supervisors always better than the
surprise so like I run a clustering and
I find the six subtypes of autism down
you I work on a lots on the psychiatric
imaging that's part of me [ __ ]
because then I should just have run a
supervised algorithm on this so the not
saying you shouldn't look at whatever
Nathan factors or clusters do you've
used and at least try to interpret this
I'm convinced about looking at the data
and interpreting but that's not ground
for justification it's post hoc
expectation so but this this work was
you take I mean the value of
unsupervised learning is that can use
data without labels so just use this as
as a feature engineering I'm a big fan
of using dictionary to learn reduced
representation or an augmented
representation depending on your problem
whether you're in you know sample
emitted or feature limited and then use
the representation on the dictionary
learning for for a supervised learning
the first thing I should say is I don't
know because I am the regime of typical
deep learning methods so computer vision
with a million samples so I don't know
the line paper applies it to neural nets
so you know in theory it should be
practical it should be useful there's
nothing nothing that he knows but in
practice I don't know it's important to
have in mind that lime and feature
importances are looking at very
different things right feature
importance says you know some aspect
it's not a local measure it's it's it's
integrated over over at least at the
whole range of of this of this feature
trying to condition on the neighbors
whereas lime is something local that's
it I mean the important thing is are you
trying to be local or you're trying to
be global you know if you want to give a
recommendation to someone which is more
sensor base or policy based then you
might want some form of a global
recommendation you know I need to add
this sensor there I need to acquire this
data on the patients but if you want to
so in which case you need more partial
dependency plots or future importances
or things like this if you want to give
a local recognition than you need lime
and the only place where the two match
is when you have a linear model
thank you Karen just one moment just
before holder doctor claps I'm just
gonna plug myself oh this girl leaps off
the stage I'm talking on a very similar
topic at 11:00 tomorrow on creating
correct classifiers and I investigate a
different set of tools to go and I hope
the girl will join me and then critique
some of my slides as well and we can
learn some more about this is
complicated and an important topic and
right now I'll be finishing at five
o'clock in here and then we're going to
the pub just over the destroy and the
back of the the conference center
overlooking the dock the Dickens pub
it's a great big huge brown wooden
building and this come along and join us
for a drink and then we'll kick off
tomorrow morning at eight to nine for
registration so let's finish off now and
thank Gael for that
you